hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play poky slender
ok so someone suggested this yesterday
and basically after Slendy Tubby's i'm
not going to turn out anything that
sounds as absurd as this but it's
probably amazing so I don't know what's
wrong with me my Pokemon they were my
life but now they are gone everyone is
blaming me but no one understands my
pain I am all alone now my pokeballs the
same ones that contained once contained
my dear Pokemon
they were my only companion but now they
are missing so I will openly admit I'm
not a huge fit i watch poke him in a
while ago but I'm not the biggest
pokeyman guy pokeyman Pokemon guy so
today I saw a dream it was unclear but
made some sort of sense to me I should
follow my senses I think I'm going
paranoid but I don't have a choice I am
NOT going to write down what I am going
to do I will find my pokeballs if it is
the last thing I do
I may write the next page of my diary if
I'm lucky if I haven't then dot dot dot
what you just said you weren't gonna
write what you're gonna do and then you
say you're gonna find your pokeballs if
there's the last thing you do keen to
write logic logic ok hello are you the
poky slender okay let's see controls uh
pretty much the same as all okay here we
go change radius what does that mean my
pokeballs are scattered here hahahaha Oh
looks nice it's obviously made on the
Unity engine so same engine as slender
is I mean there are quite a few clones
out there that bus is actually kind of
tiny now that I'm looking at it okay so
I gotta find my pokeballs radius me
woohoo that's what radius meant
okay so I can see things close far in
the distance
and then medium so I'll be closed for
now haha I can actually see you mean
this flashlight actually works which
isn't really a flashlight cuz it's just
a beam of light but whatevs
whatevs brick what is this a gym a
pokeyman maan gym all you pokemon fans
are gonna be very upset at me by the end
of this oh this looks downright nice I
mean flat textures and all but still
nice see and that away cuz you turned it
off in here oh is that a pokeball oh
really
can you ha ah
what the hell what is that what is that
what is this flat ghosts ha ha
Hey Baby how you doing have you seen my
pokeballs yeah yeah
ow okay alright enough of that I don't
see another one over here probably means
there is not one over here so let us go
back downstairs where it is safe
quote-unquote a brain is awfully loud
alright that will not dissuade me I
don't know if all the other pokeballs
are in buildings what gym where are they
damn
who's gonna run this way in a left early
divock direction I didn't even see him
the door I'm spinning wait was that well
that's my van hey Sonny you want to get
in the back of my van oh what's this oh
it's a wall or a log no it's a wall let
me just check the corner make sure
there's nothing over here I got sprayed
up very good Bob
holiday guy your dog
back I I can't run at all I see eyes I
know those are the brake lights what's
going on I can't navigate through these
trees I'm like do fat cannot make uh uh
okay so it team said whatever was
chasing me one away I think I saw a
spout of blood but I'm not exactly sure
I'm not sure what I'm looking for
besides a pokeballs but I mean in terms
of the monster not sure what I'm trying
to run away from see can't see anything
in the distance that is kind of handy
there's some strategy to the light
because you can focus a beam to see far
away I see medium and then close but I
don't see any other stro I didn't see
anything let's just go man let's go man
there's a big path on the outside it's
like a circular path or anything in like
in the forest I don't know if the all
the Pokemon balls are gonna be pokemon
balls I'm not
I watched back when there were 151
Pokemon not when there were 400 some I
recently picked up a book and I saw the
stupidest Pokemon I've ever seen in my
life it was a Bidoof it's just the
goofiest looking beaver Pokemon hello
it's probably my favorite I just looked
at the Bidoof and I knew instantly that
I liked it oh hello here we go another
building oh good ha go away go away you
dick
hi I thought that oh man where is a
friggin entrance oh you mean I could
have gone left and I would have been at
the entrance yeah I can't read for
anything
I cannot sprint at all stop it what my
sanity is dropping I see why can't what
is going on my sanity is very low or no
it's going back up never mind okay can I
get through this doorway please god damn
its gimme gimme gimme gimme
Oh Sam what are you talking about game
let me through the damn door to rot
okay so I got a jump every time I want
to go through a door that's that's
that's intuitive
no wonder stairs don't work what I don't
see him you got to stop that game you
shouldn't be able to be affected by him
through walls okay all right okay
everything's just hunky-dory I'm jumping
over the little curbs where where he's
not there he's not there hobbit yeah I
don't see it a dong dong dong I don't
see another Pokemon that's kind of weird
I don't see any other Pokemon
stop with the piano it's not that
dramatic my sanity is still dropping a
lot huh oh right whatever I've got two
pokeballs just get out of here there
must be a bunch of other buildings in
here at this stop doing that he's not
there he she it is not there where I
want to see it I actually do if it's
there
show it to me but if it's not stop
playing the music there are apparently
only six pokeballs I've got a little
counter up in the top left behind my
face that you guys can't see but
apparently there are six oh wait I think
I saw something over there
if I could just get through these trees
god I cannot navigate for anything my
maneuverability sucks so bad is this a
different building got to be a different
there's no way I just wanted a circle
did I did I did I did I honestly just no
no there's no way there is no way I went
in at a completely different direction
there's no why what what I would I don't
even make sense
hang on did I just go in a circle I
think I just Oh Cemetery oh there's
gotta be good oh look it's another
pokeball bogey ball bogey ball
I'm sorry learn me too
I didn't want my pokemons bogey in the
mouth fire that was a man sir a maza I
can sprint at all I'm so tired who this
breathe
hi al good guy that there are two of
them there to harm
but the big thing with a spiralize
Cheston and the ion was big and black
and scary okay hahaha
Wow okay all right so that's it for now
I've done so try it for yourself the
link is in the description below it was
good though
I mean besides a few bugs but those
those can be worked out with a gameplay
modifications but overall out pretty
good I ran right towards that thing I
thought it was a foot I thought I saw a
little red in the distance and it was
just the guy's mouth so anyway thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye same thing
haha definitely stay on the road as long
as I can